chances in Montana
I can't welcome to Dave Ramsey show I
did thanks for taking my call
how are you today better than I deserve
sir how can I help
damn I I've been kind of 32 years old
and been really bad with money and just
started listening to you here over the
weekend and really intrigued while
you're teaching and and how to go about
doing it about 150,000 and yet between
bad mistakes on get-rich-quick schemes
and credit cards and vehicle loans and a
house loan just kind of wondering what
your advice is to go about getting back
three cool so uh how much do you owe on
your home I owe about forty thousand
okay and how much on credit cards right
now it's right around fifteen okay how
much on the car nine thousand okay so
you've got like $90,000 on
get-rich-quick schemes no I have I've
bought out credit cards with loans
I've got about I have one loan for
fifteen thousand then I've got another
loan I think it's sitting at 15,000 and
I read about 10,000 and get-rich-quick
schemes you know getting credit cards to
buy the product so you can you know get
rich fast whatever so what kind of a
get-rich-quick scheme did you get into
they called it kangen water and that in
magic they what I guess you had to buy
these products and then try to sell it
over the Facebook well advertised means
not cheap so you spend a bunch of money
on that and and I didn't have the money
to do any of it to begin with and to buy
the products was right around $12,000 to
do it okay and so what's your household
income I'm right now eighty thousand
here in the summer the winner will
probably drop okay
so what do you do for a living I joined
the railroad got laid off and now I'm in
construction okay good all right
so what did you learn from losing money
on the get-rich-quick things that it's
pretty much what you say it's not
everything it's put up to be yeah well
just I mean you don't get rich quick
most people get rich slow exactly and
you spend a lot of money doing it and
you get nowhere you know and so very
very very few people become wealthy in a
short period of time the vast majority
of millionaires that we've studied and
we've done the largest study of
millionaires and America ever done over
ten thousand millionaires we've studied
the vast majority of them took over a
decade minimum usually two decades
somewhere in there to become to build
their first million dollars now there
are occasionally somebody that just
strikes it rich right that's why they
call it strike it rich it's like a gold
strike it's a rarity it's a low
percentage play it's a lottery ticket
and most of us know most of those aren't
worth anything and so what I would tell
you is just to you know you kind of
mentioned that in your opening to me so
I would just say make sure that that
what you learn from it was that okay I'm
gonna use a different system or a
different mindset a different philosophy
about wealth in order to get some and
that is I'm gonna be the tortoise rather
than the hare you remember the old lease
ops fable The Tortoise and the hare and
the tortoise wins every time I read the
book yeah yeah so now you've been trying
to be the hare didn't work you lost the
race I did that too by the way it's how
I went broke in my 20s only I did it a
lot bigger than you I had lots of zeros
on the end I got a PhD in D U and B so
you can you can turn this around you're
just going to get very systematic and
become a marathoner rather than a
sprinter and just just lay into this
thing so what we're going to do is we're
going to put you into a financial piece
of membership which includes the nine
week class two Financial Peace
University it includes one-year
connectivity to the every dollar app I'm
gonna pay for it I'm gonna give it to
you okay if I do that with you in your
class we've I do that will you and your
wife commit to going to the class
okay and we'll walk you through exactly
how to get on a budget and and from that
then start to analyze your situation and
begin to work your way through these
debts and you can work your way right
through these these are very doable but
you've been just stumbling along and
every time you stub your toe you borrow
ten grand and because that's what these
increments are they're all ten fifteen
thousand bucks all the way up through
here and it's a ten thousand dollar car
fifteen thousand credit cards fifteen
thousand our loan fifteen thousand our
loan ten thousand dollar Colligan I mean
that's just you know it just doesn't
didn't work so we need to do ten
thousand dollar increments the other
direction and get this mess cleaned up
and so it's gonna take you a couple
years of sacrifice and of watching what
you're doing and limiting your lifestyle
and being very intentional with every
dollar but you'll be able to turn it
around and we'll show you exactly how to
do that in this non week course with the
one-year membership so don't don't take
it all in it's all included in it's all
free I gave it all to you